[Music]  this show has all kinds of fans fans of  all ages all all if you happen to be a  fan of mine over the age of 50 this next  piece is just for you please welcome the  bowel  owl who's there oh hi everyone yeah I  fly all over the world teaching folks  about colon health by teaching them  about ow I'm sorry colon health and owls  I don't see the connection I will show  you how fat owls have tiny cold-like  rich feathers on their wings that  disrupt sound waves and allow them to  fly silently toward their prey you know  who else is a silent killer  who colorectal disease if you're over 50  it's time to give a hoot about your put  to good day sir hey there you're a  horrible character I said good day  [Applause]  so Jose that was livestream to your  father  Oh for god sakes I can't go home that  was fantastic  [Music]  you